the entire world is about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
our entire planet wakes up in mass
confusion
no one knows where or who they are
while the mcu has spider-man and dr
strange to fix this mess
our world
wouldn't be as lucky
so
what would happen if everyone's memories
disappeared
could this event create an alternate
timeline
would this memory loss cure your trauma
and would it completely erase your
personality too
this is what if and here's what would
happen if everyone's memories were
erased
your mind creates memories in three
stages
first you encode what you learned or
experienced then this information gets
stored in the depths of your mind
finally you recall these memories to
remember faces interests perform simple
tasks or stay alive
but some events are so traumatic that
your brain might suppress those memories
or create an alternative version of
events
this internal process might protect you
from reliving painful memories
erasing harmful moments could help you
cope better but
what would replace the original memories
in spider-man no way home the sorcerer
supreme attempts to erase everyone's
memories of the hero's secret identity
peter parker
but if everyone's memories disappeared
chaos could reign in the streets
this wouldn't be like amnesia
that condition often brought on by
health problems or physical trauma can
make it harder for you to form new
memories or learn
with this total mind wipe the details
that make up your life and personality
could be gone forever
but are doctors already erasing memories
well in therapy sessions some doctors
have implanted false memories in
patients to help get rid of their fears
well that treatment is questionable but
if the experiences that shaped your life
were replaced by fiction
would that change who you are
removing traumatic memories could help
many people cope better with everyday
life but it would take away every moment
that brought you joy too
your favorite band may become noise to
you
the old web head may want to forget the
time thanos snapped him out of existence
but
he wouldn't remember his first kiss
either
no not that one wrong timeline
and with your memories gone
what would happen to all the knowledge
you've gained
as you learn and develop skills your
brain creates synaptic roots that pass
signals faster
as you repeat specific actions these
tasks become automatic
these are procedural memories so even if
your memories are gone you could still
remember life skills like riding
swimming or even driving a car
but you could lose your declarative
memories that's information that
requires effort to remember
so while a pilot may remember how to fly
they may not know where they're going
now if everyone's minds were completely
distorted
would this change the fabric of our
universe
without your memories
everyone from your former life would be
a stranger
photos and keepsakes of your loved ones
wouldn't seem real
your mind could start to blur memories
and imagination
so
unlike the film the reality of our
timeline wouldn't change
just your perception of it
and while everyone in the marvel
universe might forget spider-man's
secret identity
so would spider-man
well unless doctor strange had a
customized spell for the wall crawler
losing your memories and starting fresh
could be just as traumatic as any pain
you've already experienced but
what if
this was just a glitch in the system
what if we were living in a computer
simulation
well adjust your tinfoil hat because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you